On the 18th of April 1943, four young boys discovered a skeleton buried in the hollow of a witch arm tree in Hagley Woods, in the Worcestershire County of England. Police immediately got to work on identifying the remains and trying to determine the cause of death. However, the investigation hit a wall pretty early on. There were no witnesses, no physical evidence, no suspects, no real leads at all. They couldn't even identify the remains. But about eight months later, the messages started to appear around town.
1943年4月18日，四个小男孩在英国伍斯特郡黑格利森林（Hagley Woods）的一棵魔女榆树（Witch elm）树洞里，发现了一具被埋葬的骨骼。警察立即着手查明遗骸身份并试图确定死因。然而，调查很早就陷入了僵局。没有目击证人，没有物证，没有嫌疑人，根本没有任何真正的线索。他们甚至无法辨认遗骸的身份。但在大约八个月后，小镇各处开始出现一些讯息。
Scrawled in white chalk across walls and abandoned buildings. Who put Bella in the witch arm? Hagley Woods is part of Hagley Hall Estate, which is privately owned by Lord Cobham. It is located in the Worcestershire County in England, part of the West Midlands region. Hagley Hall Estate is about 350 acres in size, and as the name suggests, Hagley Woods are a secluded, quiet, wooded area. The village of Hagley lies at the foot of the Clint Hills and is bordered by Stourbridge and the Black Country. The nearest major city is Birmingham, which is about 27 kilometers away,
这些字迹是用白色粉笔潦草地写在墙壁和废弃建筑上的：“是谁把贝拉放进魔女榆树里的？”黑格利森林是黑格利庄园（Hagley Hall Estate）的一部分，该庄园由科巴姆勋爵（Lord Cobham）私人所有。它位于英国伍斯特郡，属于西米德兰兹地区的一部分。黑格利庄园占地约350英亩，顾名思义，黑格利森林是一个人迹罕至、安静的林区。黑格利村坐落在克林特山（Clint Hills）脚下，与斯图尔布里奇（Stourbridge）和黑乡（Black Country）相邻。最近的大城市是伯明翰，距离约27公里，
or 17 miles. We start this story by going back to April 18, 1943. World War II is still raging, and the nearby city of Birmingham is still suffering heavy bombing by the German Air Force, known as the Luftwaffe. The bombing raids came to be known as the Birmingham Blitz. Birmingham was an important industrial and manufacturing area for the war. Lots of weapons ammunition and supplies came from Birmingham. This made it a prime target for the Nazis.
或者说17英里。我们把这个故事的时间拨回到1943年4月18日。第二次世界大战仍在激烈进行，附近的伯明翰市依然遭受着德国空军（即“德国国防军空军”）的猛烈轰炸。这些轰炸突袭后来被称为“伯明翰闪电战”（Birmingham Blitz）。对战争而言，伯明翰是一个重要的工业和制造业基地。大量的武器、弹药和物资都产自伯明翰。这使其成为纳粹的主要目标。
During the time of the Birmingham Blitz, there were over 365 air raid alerts put out, with 77 actual air raid bombings going ahead. Thousands of people were killed, over 10,000 houses were destroyed, and hundreds of factories. Apart from there being wartime restrictions, such as rations, food and resource shortages, and despite the fact there were planes flying overhead, they weren't getting bombed. So, four school friends from Stourbridge, Fred Payne, Bob Farmer, Thomas Willits, and Robert Hart, were pretty much free to do what young boys do. Go outside, explore, play, and see what mischief they could find.
在伯明翰闪电战期间，当地发布了365次以上的空袭警报，其中77次真正的空袭轰炸付诸实施。数千人丧生，超过10,000栋房屋和数百家工厂被摧毁。除了存在战时限制（如配给制、食物和资源短缺）之外，尽管头顶上有飞机飞过，但他们并没有遭到轰炸。因此，来自斯图尔布里奇的四个学校好友——弗雷德·佩恩（Fred Payne）、鲍勃·法默（Bob Farmer）、托马斯·威利茨（Thomas Willits）和罗伯特·哈特（Robert Hart）——几乎可以自由地做年轻男孩们常做的事：出门、探索、玩耍，看看能惹出什么麻烦。
On the 18th of April 1943, the four friends ventured into the Hagley Hall estate to explore the Hagley Woods. They weren't supposed to be there. It is a private property, so they were technically trespassing. But boys will be boys. What the boys were doing will depend on what account of the case you read, but whether they were hunting rabbits, trying to pick up all those hunting birds, and reading birds' nests, or some combination of all of those things, it isn't really important. What is important is that they happen to stumble across an old hollow witchy-on tree, just begging to be climbed.
1943年4月18日，这四个朋友冒险闯入黑格利庄园去探索黑格利森林。他们本不该去那里。这是一处私有财产，所以严格来说他们是在擅闯。但男孩们总归是男孩。男孩们当时在做什么，取决于你读的是关于该案的哪份记录；但无论他们当时是在捕兔、试图捡拾那些狩猎鸟类并查看鸟巢，还是所有这些活动的组合，其实都不重要。重要的是，他们恰巧偶遇了一棵古老空心的魔女榆树，那树看上去简直就像是在引诱人去攀爬。
Bob takes the honours and climbs up the tree. He peeks down into the tree hollow and is in luck, finds what he thinks is some kind of animal. He reaches down to grab it, but he can't quite reach. Bob sings out to his mates for some help, and they end up passing him a long stick. With the help of the stick, Bob is able to reach in and pick up his find. Bob got the shock of his life when he found out his discovery wasn't an animal at all. He was staring back at a human skull. The boys gathered around in shock at the discovery, but also they were pretty curious. The skull still had some rotting flesh on the forehead, and there was still some hair attached.
鲍勃拔得头筹，爬上了树。他往树洞里探头一看，运气不错，发现了一个他认为某种动物的东西。他伸手去抓，却差了一点够不着。鲍勃大声呼喊同伴帮忙，最后他们递给他一根长棍子。借助棍子的帮助，鲍勃终于够进去并拿起了他的发现物。当鲍勃发现自己的藏品根本不是什么动物时，他受到了此生最大的惊吓。他正与一个人类头骨对视。男孩们震惊地聚拢过来围观这个发现，但同时也充满了好奇。头骨的前额上还带有部分腐烂的肉，上面还连着一些头发。
They then started to chat amongst themselves about what they should do with the discovery. The idea to tell their parents who was quickly shot down, they were trespassing. They didn't want to get in trouble. So they make it packed. They put the skull back and forget about it. They'll never speak of it again. Well that secret pack didn't even last the day. Thomas Willis was very uneasy and was struggling to come to terms with the discovery. They didn't take long for his parents to work out something was up, and Thomas broke down in tears and spilled the beans to his father, who in turn quickly called the police. Sergeant Charles Lamborn of the Worcestershire County Police arrived soon after.
随后，他们开始私下讨论该如何处理这个发现。把这事告诉父母的想法很快被否决了，因为他们是擅闯者。他们不想惹麻烦。于是他们订立了保密协议。他们把头骨放了回去并将其抛诸脑后。他们再也不谈论此事了。然而，这个保密协议连一天都没维持过去。托马斯·威利茨感到十分不安，一直在努力克服这个发现带来的心理压力。没过多久，他的父母就看出不对劲了，托马斯泪流满面地向父亲吐露了实情，而他的父亲随即迅速报了警。伍斯特郡警察局的查尔斯·兰博恩（Charles Lamborn）警长不久后赶到了现场。
Together with the help of Thomas and the other boys, they managed to track down the tree in Hangley Woods. Other police arrived soon after, but it was getting dark. No portable lighting in those days. So they made a decision to guard the tree overnight until the next morning when detectives and forensic experts would arrive. The police didn't guard the tree themselves. They only said the help of local special constables and trusted volunteers. Keep in mind the police force was severely weakened due to the war. A lot of officers volunteered to go and fight. There were a number of officers who were reservists and they were called up to active duty. And there were the retired military men within the police ranks who were called
在托马斯和其他男孩的帮助下，他们设法找到了黑格利森林里的那棵树。其他警察随后也赶到了，但天色渐暗。那个年代可没有便携式照明设备。因此，他们决定派人连夜看守这棵树，直到第二天早晨侦探和法医专家到来。警察并没有亲自看守这棵树。他们仅动用了当地的特别警察（special constables）和信得过的志愿者。请记住，由于战争，警察队伍的实力严重削弱。许多警官自愿参军作战。还有许多预备役警官被征召入现役。此外，警界中还有几位退休的军事人员也被召
back to duty. To combat a loss of numbers, the police force was propped up with special constables and bought new recruiting. So maybe the standards weren't quite as high as what they would have been during non-war time. I'm not suggesting the police who handled this case were incompetent or inexperienced. There were still experienced police who remained and they very could well have been from the experienced side. But it just gives you some idea of what was happening with policing at the time. That next morning, the 19th of April 1943, Detective Superintendent Sidney Knight arrives and takes charge of the investigation. He is assisted by Deputy Inspector Thomas Williams and Professor James Webster who is from the Forensic Science Laboratory at Birmingham University.
回了岗位。为了应对人手短缺，警方通过招募特别警察和开展新一轮招聘来支撑警力。所以，标准可能不像非战争时期那么高。我并不是暗示处理此案的警察无能或缺乏经验。队伍中仍然留有经验丰富的警察，这其中很可能就有经验老道的人。但这也让你对当时警务工作的状况有了一些了解。第二天清晨，即1943年4月19日，侦探总督察西德尼·奈特（Sidney Knight）抵达现场并接管了调查。协助他的是副督察托马斯·威廉姆斯（Thomas Williams）以及来自伯明翰大学法医科学实验室的詹姆斯·韦伯斯特（James Webster）教授。
Along with the skull, they quickly find that there is in fact an entire skeleton stuffed inside the hollow of the tree. But they're unable to conduct a proper examination of the remains as the gap in the tree is too small. So they find an axe and cut the tree to allow better examination. They ended up having to cut the whole tree down in order to get the remains here. At the scene, they find a green bottle, but it's later determined that it was unrelated to the case. They also find an identity card belonging to a woman. At first the police thought they had just identified the remains, but they later found the woman alive and well, although somewhat shocked as to how her identity card got to Haigley Woods, a place she has never
除了头骨，他们很快发现树洞里其实塞着一整具骨架。但由于树上的缺口太小，他们无法对遗骸进行彻底的检查。于是他们找来一把斧头砍树以便进行更好的检查。为了把遗骸弄出来，他们最终不得不把整棵树都砍倒了。在现场，他们发现了一个绿色的瓶子，但后来证实这与此案无关。他们还发现了一张属于某位女性的身份证。起初警方以为他们刚确认了遗骸的身份，但后来他们发现这位女性活得好好的，虽然对于自己的身份证是如何落入黑格利森林——一个她从未去过的地方——感到有些震惊。
been before. Apart from those items, police also had the clothing that was worn by whoever's remains were found inside the tree. The clothing included a mustard-coloured cloth skirt, a peach silk underskirt, a dark blue and yellow striped cardigan with a light blue belt, and a pair of blue crepes sold shoes. The clothing was rotting away and was in poor condition, but there was enough to tell what was there. Along with the clothing, they also found a cheap wedding ring. The skeleton was found to be almost complete, but there was one obvious part missing, the right hand. A source of the surrounding area found the hand nearby, only about 10 metres away from the tree. Again, depending on what account of the story you want to go with, some say the hand was buried,
除了这些物品，警方还拿到了死者遗骸在树内被发现时所穿的衣物。这些衣物包括：一件芥末黄色的布质裙子、一件桃色真丝衬裙、一件带有浅蓝色腰带的深蓝黄色相间开衫，以及一双蓝色呢绒平底鞋。这些衣物正在腐烂，状况很差，但足以辨认出原本的物品。除了衣物，他们还发现了一枚廉价的结婚戒指。经查，这具骨架几乎是完整的，但有一个明显的缺失部位——右手。周围区域的一处搜寻发现，右手就在附近，距离树木仅约10米远。同样，根据你倾向于相信的故事版本，有人说右手是被埋起来的，
but other accounts say it wasn't. A post-mortem was conducted soon after and Professor Webster finds that the remains belonged to a woman aged between 35 and 40 years old. She was only short, about five feet tall. She had mid-brown coloured hair. There was someone she may have had a baby, although it was inconclusive. What was significant is that she had noticeably regularities in the front teeth of a lower jaw. She was also missing a tooth from the lower right side of a jaw and it was thought that this tooth had been extracted within one year of her death. It was determined the wedding ring had been worn for about four years prior to death, and the actual time of death itself was estimated to be 18 months to two years prior to her being
但也有其他说法称并没有。不久后进行了尸检，韦伯斯特教授发现遗骸属于一名35至40岁左右的女性。她个头不高，大约五英尺（约1.5米）高。她有着中棕色的头发。她可能生过孩子，尽管这一点尚无定论。重要的是，她下颌的前牙有明显的特征性不规则。她下颌右侧还缺了一颗牙，据认为这颗牙在她死前一年内被拔除过。经确定，那枚结婚戒指在她死前大约佩戴了四年，而实际死亡时间估计在她被发现前18个月到两年之间，
found, which would put it between April and October 1941. The remains showed no indications of disease and the bones themselves showed no physical signs of violence. There were no breaks, no fractures, but the fact she was stuffed into a tree hollow and a right hand had been cut off was enough to suggest she had met a violent end, but there was something else. A piece of taffeta was found stuffed into the mouth of the skull. Taffeta is a piece of silk or synthetic fabric. This would later lead the coroner to conclude that the woman had been murdered by way of asphyxiation. He also concluded the body would have been put inside the tree while it was still warm, either while still alive or just after death, as the gap would have been too narrow
也就是在1941年4月到10月之间。遗骸没有显示出疾病迹象，骨骼本身也没有暴力的物理迹象。没有骨折，没有裂痕，但她被塞进树洞且右手被砍断这一事实，足以表明她遭遇了暴力结局，不过还有别的情况。人们在头骨嘴里塞入了一块塔夫绸（taffeta）。塔夫绸是一种丝绸或合成织物。这后来导致验尸官得出结论：这名女性是被窒息杀害的。他还断定，尸体是在尚有余温时被放入树中的，要么是在生前，要么就在死后不久，因为如果尸体已经出现了死后僵硬（rigor mortis），树洞的缝隙就会太窄，
to get the body in if it was affected by rigor mortis. There are two alternate theories as to how the piece of taffeta came to be stuffed inside the mouth. The first suggests that when police were conducting their examination, the skull fell out of the tree along with a piece of taffeta. The police assumed the taffeta was stuffed inside the mouth, but they didn't actually see if it was. Regardless, they put it back in. The second theory suggests that the boys who made the initial discovery actually put the piece of taffeta inside the mouth, and apparently they later admitted this in interviews. However, nothing has been officially released and the police file is still closed, so there's no way of telling for sure. The case is surrounded with
根本无法将尸体塞进去。关于这块塔夫绸是如何被塞进嘴里的，有两种不同的理论。第一种理论认为，当警察进行检查时，头骨连同一块塔夫绸一起从树上掉了下来。警察假设塔夫绸是塞在嘴里的，但他们其实并没有亲眼看到是否如此。不管怎样，他们还是把它塞了回去。第二种理论认为，最初做出这一发现的男孩们实际上把这块塔夫绸塞进了嘴里，而且据称他们在后来的采访中承认了这一点。然而，官方并未公布任何信息，警察档案目前仍处于保密状态，因此无法确切得知真相。这个案子被各种
hearsay, folklore, and trunnies whispers that have been passed on over the years, so various parts of the case each have several different versions. Given the police file has remained closed, it's difficult to determine what information is fact and what information has been twisted over the years. But regardless, if the taffeta was or wasn't stuffed inside the mouth, I think it's pretty clear the unknown woman met a violent, unnatural death. The police immediately got to work on searching through missing person reports. They searched through over 3,000 across the entire country. It was clear the woman wasn't from the local area as somebody would have missed her by now. Despite an exhaustive search through the records,
多年来流传下来的传闻、民间传说和窃窃私语所包围，因此案件的各个部分都有几种不同的版本。鉴于警方档案一直保密，很难确定哪些信息是事实，哪些信息是多年来被扭曲了的。但无论如何，不管塔夫绸当时有没有被塞进嘴里，我认为很明显，这位身份不明的女性遭遇了一场暴力且非自然的死亡。警方立即着手查阅失踪人员报告。他们在全国范围内搜索了3,000多起报告。很明显，这位女性不是当地人，否则现在早就有人发现她失踪了。尽管对记录进行了详尽的搜索，
they found no match. The police were certain they would be able to identify the woman through dental records, as she had tooth irregularities and the extracted tooth. They conducted checks with every dentist in England, but again they got no match. Police got to work on the items found at the scene. The grain bottle was a dead end, but they did track the woman's shoes to a North Hampton manufacturer. The manufacturer reported 6,000 pairs of the shoes were made, most being sold at retail outlets, but some sold at markets. The shoes were a dead end, there was no way they were going to be able to trace them to an owner. It was also discovered that all of the labels had been cut out from the unknown woman's clothing. But as the clothing was rotten,
但他们没有找到任何匹配的人。警方确信他们能够通过牙科记录识别这名女性的身份，因为她有牙齿不规则和被拔除的牙齿。他们与英国的所有牙医进行了核对，但同样没有找到匹配者。警方开始着手调查在现场发现的物品。绿瓶子是一条死胡同，但他们确实追踪到了这名女性的鞋子产自北安普敦（North Hampton）的一家制造商。该制造商报告称，他们生产了6,000双这种鞋，大部分在零售店销售，但也有一些在市场上出售。鞋子是一条死胡同，根本无法追溯到鞋的主人。人们还发现，死者衣物上的所有标签都被剪掉了。但由于衣物已经腐烂，
it was difficult to tell if they were deliberately cut out to avoid identification, or if the clothing had been bought secondhand and so the labels were cut out as someone had written their name on it. So not only did the police have no witnesses, no suspects and no evidence, they also had no idea who the unknown woman was. So basically they had nothing. They had hit a brick wall in a dead end street. As the months went on, people started to lose interest in the unknown woman case. The case had gone cold and World War II was still in full swing. But about eight months after the unknown woman was found, the case would take a twist. In December of 1943, the first of many messages appeared. This first message was
很难判断是为了逃避身份识别而故意剪掉的，还是因为衣服是买的二手货，别人在上面写了名字所以才把标签剪掉了。因此，警方不仅没有目击证人、没有嫌疑人和没有证据，甚至连死者是谁都不知道。基本上他们一无所获。调查陷入了死胡同。随着时间的推移，人们开始对这个无名女性的案件失去兴趣。案件已经变冷，而第二次世界大战仍在全面激战中。但在无名女性被发现大约八个月后，案情迎来了转机。1943年12月，许多留言中的第一条出现了。这第一条留言是
scrolled across an abandoned building on Upper Dean Street in Birmingham. The message was written with chalk and capital letters about three inches in height, and it read, Who put Lubella down the witchel? Suddenly the police and the public were very interested again. Who wrote this message? Was it local teenagers playing a troll trick? Was it the killer taunting the police? Was it the killer throwing the police a false lead by writing the incorrect name? Was it somebody who knew something they shouldn't too scared to come forward instead deciding to leave a clue? It's anyone's guess who wrote the message, but it wasn't the only one written. It was the first of many. Soon after another message appeared, Hagley Wood Beller,
用粉笔潦草地写在伯明翰上迪恩街（Upper Dean Street）的一栋废弃建筑上。留言是用粉笔写的约三英寸高的大写字母，上面写着：“是谁把卢贝拉塞进魔女榆树里的？”（Who put Lubella down the witchel?）突然之间，警方和公众再次对该案产生了浓厚的兴趣。是谁写了这条留言？是当地青少年在恶作剧吗？是凶手在嘲弄警方吗？是凶手写下错误的名字来误导警方吗？还是某个知道本不该知道的内情、却又因害怕而不敢露面转而决定留下线索的人？谁也说不准究竟是谁写下了这条留言，但这并不是唯一的一条。它是许多留言中的第一条。不久之后，另一条留言出现了：“黑格利森林贝拉，”
also written in chalk in the same writing as the first message. And not long after that, another message. Who put Beller in the witchel? Again in the same writing. The messages were appearing all around the local area. Birmingham, Old Country, Orsesta, Hagley. The writings have continued, albeit sporadically, to this day. Although it's since changed from chalk to paint, and it's believed the later messages are definitely copycats or locals trying to keep the tradition alive. But those first messages were a lead for police. Neither the police or anyone from the media or the public had ever referred to the unknown woman as Lou Beller or Beller. Police got back to work on the missing person reports trying to find a
同样是用粉笔以第一条留言相同的字迹写的。不久之后，又出现了一条留言：“是谁把贝拉放进魔女榆树里的？”同样是相同的字迹。这些留言开始在当地各个地方出现：伯明翰、老康特里（Old Country）、奥尔瑟斯塔（Orsesta）、黑格利。这些字迹一直延续至今，尽管断断续续。虽然此后粉笔换成了油漆，而且人们认为后来的留言肯定是由模仿者或当地人为了保持这个传统而写下的。但最初的那些留言对警方来说是一条线索。无论是警方、媒体还是公众，以前从未有人将这个无名女性称为“卢贝拉”或“贝拉”。警方重新开始查阅失踪人员报告，试图寻找
match for Lou Beller, Beller or any name containing variants of Beller such as Isabella. But again, they came up short. Police appealed for the writer of the messages to come forward, but I don't think anyone was surprised when they didn't. Police were never able to identify who was responsible for writing the messages. They certainly added a great deal of mystery to the case, but what they also did was give the unknown woman a name. She would now be known as Beller. Police went back through their previous incident reports from around the time that was thought that Beller was killed. And they found something interesting. In July 1941, they responded to a report of a woman heard screaming in Haigley Woods. Police conducted a patrol, but they were
与卢贝拉、贝拉或包含贝拉变体（如伊abella）的名字相匹配的人。但结果依然一无所获。警方呼吁留言的撰写者主动现身，但我想当没有人站出来时，谁也不会感到惊讶。警方始终未能查明是谁负责写下这些留言。它们无疑为案件增添了大量神秘感，但它们的另一个作用是赋予了这个无名女性一个名字。她现在被称为“贝拉”。警方查阅了贝拉被认为遇害时间前后的以往事件报告。他们发现了一些有趣的东西。1941年7月，他们接到了一起报警，称听到黑格利森林里传出女性的尖叫声。警方进行了巡逻，但
unable to locate anything or anyone of interest. July 1941 fits with Beller's estimated time of death, so these reports could very well be linked. They immediately re-interviewed the person who made the report, but they learnt nothing new. All the witness could offer was that they heard screams, and they saw nothing. Were these the screams of Beller? There were all sorts of theories, speculation and tip-offs that had come in. There was Warwick Plaint, the son of a local publican who reported a woman, gave her name as Beller, turned up to his parents' pub to play piano. In return, Warwick's mother gave her a pair of blue crepes old shoes. There was the theory that Beller was fleeing nearby Birmingham to escape with bombing and had crossed paths with a rapist
未能找到任何相关的人或物。1941年7月与贝拉的估计死亡时间相吻合，因此这些报告很有可能存在关联。他们立即重新盘问了报案人，但没有得到任何新信息。目击者能提供的只是他们听到了尖叫声，但什么也没看到。这些是贝拉的尖叫声吗？各种各样的理论、猜测和线索纷至沓来。沃里克·普兰特（Warwick Plaint）是当地一家酒馆老板的儿子，他报告说有一个自称贝拉的女人来到他父母的酒吧弹钢琴。作为回报，沃里克的母亲送了她一双蓝色呢绒平底鞋。还有一种理论认为，贝拉当时正逃离附近的伯明翰以躲避轰炸，在途中遇到了强奸犯
or serial killer on her journey. There was the local clergy members who came up with the theory that Beller was a gypsy who was killed due to some sort of punishment by her fellow gypsies, even though the gypsies weren't named to commit murders as punishment, and Beller's clothing did not match what a gypsy would wear. Then there was the spy theory, or because there are several different versions going around, spy theories. The first being that Beller was a German spy who parachuted into the country and somehow managed to land in the tree hollow. Some holes were that theory, but the clothing she was wearing doesn't lead one to think she had just parachuted, and the other obvious hole. Where was the parachute? Another spy theory was raised in 1968
或连环杀手。当地的几位神职人员提出了另一种理论：贝拉是一名吉普赛人，因遭到同伴的某种惩罚而被杀害——尽管吉普赛人并无将谋杀作为惩罚的习惯，而且贝拉的衣物也不符合吉普赛人的着装。接着是间谍理论，或者由于流传着几个不同的版本，应该叫间谍理论群。第一种说法是，贝拉是一名德国间谍，她乘降落伞降落到英国境内，不知怎么竟落在了树洞里。这个理论有几个漏洞，但她当时穿的衣服并不让人觉得她刚刚跳过伞，另一个明显的漏洞是：降落伞在哪里？另一个间谍理论在1968年被提出，
when writer Donald McCormick claimed in his book Murder by Witchcraft that Beller was a Nazi spy. Her curd name, Clara. Her real name being Clara Beller. He claims to have been given access to German military intelligence papers detailing how Clara Beller was parachuted into the West Midlands area in 1941, but she never made radio contact and she was never heard from again. An ex-Nazi spy, Franz Rafgab, who was operating in the West Midlands area at the time, verified that he was aware of a fellow Nazi spy by the name of Clara Beller, drunkards, and she just so happened to have two to three realities. No aspects of Donald's story could be verified, and his book and research and the evidence that he used the basadon has been
当时作家唐纳德·麦考密克（Donald McCormick）在他的书《巫术谋杀》（Murder by Witchcraft）中声称贝拉是一名纳粹间谍。她的代号叫克拉拉。她的真名是克拉拉·贝拉。他声称自己获得了德国军事情报文件的查阅权限，这些文件详细记录了克拉拉·贝拉是如何在1941年被空投到西米德兰兹地区的，但她从未建立无线电联系，从此销声匿迹。前纳粹间谍弗朗茨·拉夫加布（Franz Rafgab）当时在西米德兰兹地区活动，他证实自己确实知道一个名叫克拉拉·贝拉的纳粹同伙，而且她刚好有两到三个真名。唐纳德故事的任何方面都无法得到证实，他的书、研究以及他用作依据的证据都被
described as somewhat loose and uneven. In 2013, the UK independent newspaper ran a story. They mentioned a declassified file about a Czech national spy named Joseph Jacobs. He was caught up to parachuting into England in 1941. When caught, it was discovered he had a photo of a woman. He gave her name as Clara Beller Lee. The back of the photo was inscribed, My dear, love you forever, your Clara, dated July 1940. It turns out Clara was a cabaret singer and German movie actress born in Stuttgart, 29th June, 1906. Her real name was Clara Sophie Beller Lee. In October 1930, she toured through England for two years, performing at various music halls
形容为有些松散和不均衡。2013年，英国《独立报》（Independent）刊登了一篇报道。他们提到了一份关于一名名叫约瑟夫·雅各布斯（Joseph Jacobs）的捷克籍间谍的解密档案。他在1941年乘降落伞潜入英国时被捕。被捕时，人们发现他身上有一张女人的照片。他给出的名字是克拉拉·贝拉·李（Clara Beller Lee）。照片背面写着：“我亲爱的，永远爱你，你的克拉拉”，日期是1940年7月。事实证明，克拉拉是一名歌舞女郎兼德国电影女演员，1906年6月29日出生于斯图加特。她的真名是克拉拉·索菲·贝拉·李（Clara Sophie Beller Lee）。1930年10月，她去英国巡回演出两年，在全国各地的各种音乐厅
throughout the country. She left England to return to Germany in June 1932. Clara spoke fluent English with the proper accent. She was referred to by English audiences as Clara Beller. Upon returning to Germany, she became well connected within the Nazi Party when it rose to power, and she later met Jacobs in Hamburg where they became romantically connected. There were claims to parachute her into England as well, however Jacobs stated that these would have been aborted when he failed to make radio contact due to his capture. Not long after his interview, Jacobs was executed. It is thought that Clara may have parachuted in any way, and Clara was Beller. But there were problems. Clara was tall.
进行表演。她于1932年6月离开英国返回德国。克拉拉能说一口流利的带有标准口音的英语。英国观众称她为“克拉拉·贝拉”。回到德国后，她在纳粹党崛起期间与之建立了紧密的联系，后来她在汉堡遇到了雅各布斯，两人发展成了恋爱关系。有说法称她也被空投到了英国，然而雅各布斯表示，由于他在被捕前未能建立无线电联系，这些行动本应被取消。不久之后，雅各布斯被处决。人们认为克拉拉可能还是跳伞进来了，而克拉拉就是贝拉。但这里面有问题。克拉拉个子很高。
Beller was not. And would the Germans really send in a spy who was a known cabaret performer and actress who had previously toured through England? That didn't really make a lot of sense. What the independent report and other people who supported this theory were relying on is that it was said to have been a trace of Clara Beller Lee backing Germany from 1941 onwards. Her singing and acting career coming to a sudden unannounced end. This combined with Jacobs' story was enough to convince people Clara was Beller from the witch home. However, the information isn't quite correct. Records show Clara did continue her career through 1941, all the way through until the 16th of December 1942, where she was killed in Berlin. Proof that there is no way Clara
而贝拉不高。德国人真的会派出一个作为知名歌舞表演者和女演员、以前还在英国巡演过的间谍吗？这实在说不通。《独立报》的报道以及支持这一理论的其他人的依据是，据说有迹象表明克拉拉·贝拉·李从1941年起就回到了德国。她的歌唱和演艺生涯戛然而止，没有发布任何公告。这结合雅各布斯的故事，足以让人确信克拉拉就是魔女树洞里的贝拉。然而，这些信息并不完全准确。记录显示，克拉拉确实在1941年继续了她的职业生涯，一直持续到1942年12月16日她在柏林遇害。这证明了克拉拉绝不
could have been Beller inside the witch home. So the first few spy theories aren't very credible, yet they're still often mentioned whenever the case is brought up. But there is one that has slightly more credit. In 1953, the Wolverhamdham Express and Star newspaper ran a series of articles on the Beller case to commemorate the 10-year anniversary. The articles were written under a pen name Q-Star. A woman who identified herself only as Anna wrote a letter into the newspaper in response to the articles. The letter read, Finish your articles regarding the witch home crime by Q-Star. They are interesting to your readers, but you will never solve their mystery. One person who could give the answer is now beyond the jurisdiction of earthly courts.
可能是魔女树洞里的贝拉。因此，前几个间谍理论并不十分可信，但每当提起这个案子时，它们仍然经常被提及。不过，有一个理论的可信度稍微高一些。1953年，《伍尔弗汉普顿快报暨明星报》（Wolverhampton Express and Star）刊登了一系列关于贝拉案的文章，以纪念案发10周年。这些文章是以笔名“Q-Star”撰写的。一位仅自称为“安娜”（Anna）的女性写了一封信给这家报社，以回应这些文章。信中写道：“请结束Q-Star关于魔女树洞罪行的文章吧。它们对你们的读者来说很有趣，但你们永远无法解开这个谜团。能够给出答案的那个人现在已经超出了尘世法庭的管辖范围。
Much as I hate having to use a non-deplume, which is a pen name, I think you would appreciate it if you knew me. The only clues I can give you are that the person responsible for the crime died insane in 1942, and the victim was Dutch and arrived illegally in England about 1941. I have no wish to recall anymore. Signed Anna from Cleverley. Anna from Cleverley was later identified as Una Mossup from Warrichier. She was identified by police and interviewed. Una's story is as follows. She was married to a man named Jack Mossup, and he was employed in a munitions factory in Birmingham during the war. He wasn't in the military and he actually had that job to avoid being called up. It was a low paying menial job,
尽管我很讨厌使用化名，但我认为如果你认识我的话，你会对此表示理解的。我能给你的唯一线索是，犯下这起罪行的人已于1942年精神失常而死，而受害者是一名荷兰人，大约在1941年非法偷渡抵达英国。我不想再回忆更多了。署名：来自克利弗利的安娜。”来自克利弗利的安娜后来被识别为来自沃里克郡的乌娜·莫苏普（Una Mossup）。她被警方识别并进行了盘问。乌娜的故事如下。她曾嫁给一个名叫杰克·莫苏普（Jack Mossup）的男子，战争期间他在伯明翰的一家军火厂工作。他不在军队里，他实际上是为了逃避兵役才找了那份工作。这是一份薪水很低且枯燥的活儿，
but suddenly in 1940 Jack started to flash some serious cash around. He didn't try and hire to do that, he was buying expensive clothes to show off and they were well above his pay grade. He also managed to purchase himself an Air Force officer's uniform that he liked to wear around to pretend he was in the military, even though he wasn't. It was around this time that Jack had become friends with a Dutchman by the name of Van Roelt. His real identity was never discovered, but Una starts to suspect that Van Roelt is working for the Nazis, and Jack is giving away secrets from them in the munitions factory in exchange for cash, which would explain his sudden new found wealth. Not long after Jack and Una separated. Jack was gone for a short period of
但突然在1940年，杰克开始大手大脚地花起大笔现金来。他并没有刻意掩饰这一点，他买昂贵的衣服来炫耀，这些远超出了他的薪资水平。他还设法给自己买了一套空军军官制服，喜欢穿在身上假装自己加入了军队，尽管他根本没有。正是在这个时候，杰克与一个名叫范·罗尔特（Van Roelt）的荷兰人交上了朋友。他的真实身份从未被查明，但乌娜开始怀疑范·罗尔特是在为纳粹效力，而杰克则在军火厂里向他们泄露秘密以换取现金，这就解释了他为什么会突然暴富。杰克和乌娜分居不久后，
time before returning to Una in 1941. He was in pretty bad shape mentally when he returned. He was making no sense, rambling about eyes in a tree staring back at him and her hand reaching out from the tree trying to grab him. Una manages to eventually calm him down and then Jack tells her the following story. One night, not long before, he was drinking with his buddy Van Roelt and a Dutch woman. They were drinking at the Littleton Arms Pub in Klint, which isn't too far from Haley Woods. Van Roelt and his Dutch woman friends started to get into an argument and so Jack agreed to take him for a drive to calm down. The drive didn't have the desired effect, and Van Roelt and the Dutch woman continued to argue. The unknown Dutch woman was threatening
杰克离开了一小段时间，然后在1941年回到了乌娜身边。他回来时精神状况相当糟糕。他语无伦次，胡言乱语地说着树上的眼睛正盯着他看，还有树里伸出一只手试图抓住他。乌娜最终设法让他冷静下来，然后杰克向她讲述了以下的故事。一天晚上，不久前，他和死党范·罗尔特以及一个荷兰女人在一起喝酒。他们在克林特（Klint）的利特尔顿阿尔姆斯酒吧（Littleton Arms Pub）喝酒，那里离黑格利森林不远。范·罗尔特和他的荷兰女性朋友开始发生争吵，于是杰克同意带他开车兜风以让其冷静下来。这次兜风并没有达到预期的效果，范·罗尔特和这名荷兰女性继续争吵。这个身份不明的荷兰女性威胁说
to expose the operation that Van Roelt and Jack were doing in selling secrets to the Nazis. Some point during the argument, Van Roelt killed the Dutch woman. Jack pulled over on the side of the road near Haley Woods and they dragged the body out and put it into the tree. Well, that's one version of the story anyway. The other version suggests they weren't arguing about that at all, and that while they were in the car, the Dutch woman just passed out. Van Roelt and Jack thought it would be funny to teach her a lesson, so they dragged her out of the car, put her inside the witch-hound tree, where they were going to leave her overnight. But when they returned the next morning, they realised that she was dead.
要揭发范·罗尔特和杰克向纳粹出卖秘密的行动。在争吵过程中的某个时刻，范·罗尔特杀死了这名荷兰女性。杰克把车停在黑格利森林附近的马路边，他们把尸体拖出来放进了树里。好吧，这毕竟是故事的一个版本。另一个版本则称他们根本不是在吵这个，而在他们在车里时，那名荷兰女性只是晕厥过去了。范·罗尔特和杰克觉得给对方一个教训会很有趣，于是他们把她从车里拖出来，放进魔女榆树里，打算把她留在那里过夜。但当他们第二天早晨返回时，他们意识到她已经死了。
Regardless of what version it actually was, it was the same outcome. Van Roelt and Jack were responsible for Bella's death. Shortly after disclosing the story, Jack had a complete breakdown and he was admitted into a mental health ward where he died two and after, aged only 29. He died in 1942, the year before Bella was even discovered, so he was never able to be interviewed. There is a piece of information that gives some weight to this theory. A witness by the name of Varyn Oliver came forward to report that her father was in the home guard at the time of Bella's death and he and a colleague regularly patrolled the Haley Woods area. One evening around 1941, they saw something suspicious. They saw a car pulled over on the side of the road near Haley Woods.
无论哪个版本是真实的，结果都是一样的。范·罗尔特和杰克对贝拉的死负有责任。在披露这个故事后不久，杰克彻底崩溃，被送进了精神病房，并在两年后死去，年仅29岁。他死于1942年，即贝拉被发现的前一年，因此他从未被盘问过。有一条信息为这个理论增添了一些分量。一位名叫瓦琳·奥利弗（Varyn Oliver）的目击者站出来报告说，在贝拉死后不久，她的父亲在国民警卫队（Home Guard）服役，他和一名同事经常在黑格利森林地区巡逻。1941年前后的一天晚上，他们看到了可疑的情况。他们看到一辆车停在黑格利森林附近的马路边。
It got their attention as it was a remote area and fuel was in seriously short supply, heavily rationed at the time. So people were in the habit of going for random drives for no reason. They approached the vehicle and saw who they thought was an Air Force officer in the driver's seat. There was a female lying in the back seat who they thought was naked, covered with a coat. Varyn's father assumed it was some sort of meeting between two lovers and he didn't think too much more of it. But thinking back now, it's quite possible that that Air Force officer was actually Jack Mossott, remembering that he liked to dress up in uniform and pretend he was in the military. Unfortunately, Ira and his father did not record details of the vehicle or the driver,
这引起了他们的注意，因为那是一个偏远地区，而且当时燃料严重短缺，实行严格的配给制。所以人们不会无缘无故地随便开车兜风。他们走近这辆车，看到驾驶座上坐着一个他们认为是空军军官的人。后座上躺着一个女性，他们以为她是赤身裸体的，身上盖着一件大衣。瓦琳的父亲以为这是某种情侣间的约会，便没有多想。但现在回想起来，那个空军军官很有可能其实就是杰克·莫苏普，因为记得他喜欢穿着制服假装自己参军了。不幸的是，伊拉和他的父亲没有记录车辆或司机的详细信息，
so it's impossible to know now. It's easy to see why the spy theory is such a popular one with this case as it's so close to Birmingham, an important industrial city for the war effort with weapons and ammunition and supplies. And because it was so important, it was heavily defended with any aircraft guns. So there was a lot of useful information there to be gathered, which makes it a prime target for spas. But whether or not bellow was a spy or in some way connected with a spy, we may never know. But there is another theory going around and it has nothing to do with spas. This theory involves the dark arts and witchcraft. The case got the attention of Professor Margaret Murray. She was an anthropologist, archaeologist and Egyptologist
所以现在已经无法得知了。不难理解为什么间谍理论在这个案件中如此受欢迎，因为它离伯明翰如此之近，而伯明翰是战时武器、弹药和物资供应的重要工业城市。正因为它的重要性，那里部署了大量防空炮进行重兵防御。因此，那里有许多有用的信息可供搜集，这使其成为间谍的主要目标。但是，贝拉是否真的是间谍，或者是否以某种方式与间谍有关，我们可能永远不得而知。然而，还有另一种流传的理论，它与间谍毫无关系。这个理论涉及黑魔法和巫术。这个案件引起了玛格丽特·默里（Margaret Murray）教授的注意。她是一位人类学家、考古学家和埃及学家，
who had an interest in the occult and witchcraft. There were even rumors circulating that she may be a dabbler in the dark arts herself. She wrote a couple of books on witchcraft which were widely slammed by her fellow academics. The case got her attention for three reasons. The first being that Bella was found inside a tree. When somebody is thought to be a witch, legend has it that by burying their body inside a tree, it's a way to trap the spirit so it could not roam and cause further harm. The second reason she was interested in the case was because Bella's right hand had been cut off. Severing a hand is a sign of black magic and its ritual name is the hand of glory. The problem with the hand of glory ritual is though, its ritual involved in cutting the
对神秘学和巫术有着浓厚的兴趣。甚至有传言称她自己也涉足黑魔法。她写过几本关于巫术的书，遭到了同行学者的广泛抨击。这个案件引起她的注意有三个原因。首先，贝拉是在一棵树里被发现的。传说中，当人们认为某人是女巫时，将他们的尸体埋在树里是一种禁锢其灵魂的方法，这样灵魂就无法四处游荡并造成进一步的危害。她对这个案子感兴趣的第二个原因是贝拉的右手被砍掉了。砍断手是黑魔法的一个标志，其仪式名称叫“光荣之手”（Hand of Glory）。然而，“光荣之手”仪式的缺陷在于，它的仪式涉及砍断
hand off from a murderer who has just been hanged. And the hand had to be cut off while they were still hanging from the gallows. The hand was then preserved and turned into a candle. Apparently it had the power to protect the inner from evil spirits, unlock doors and even find buried treasure. It was an interesting theory but there was no indication that Bella had been hanged door that she was a murderer and her hand was found nearby so it wasn't taken to be used in black magic ceremonies. The other thing that got Professor Murray's attention was the name Bella and its closer resemblance to the name Bella Donna which is significant in the world of witchcraft. Bella Donna is a plant used by witches, sorcerers and shamans to induce trans-like states. It's
一个刚刚被绞死的杀害者的手。而且必须在他们还挂在绞刑架上时将手砍下。然后这只手会被保存并变成一支蜡烛。据说它具有保护屋内人免受恶魔侵害、开锁甚至寻找埋藏宝藏的力量。这是一个有趣的理论，但没有迹象表明贝拉曾被绞死，也没有迹象表明她是个杀人犯，而且她的手是在附近被发现的，因此并非被拿去用于黑魔法仪式。引起默里教授注意的另一件事是“贝拉”（Bella）这个名字，它与“颠茄”（Belladonna）这个名字非常相似，“颠茄”在巫术世界中意义重大。颠茄是女巫、巫师和萨满用来诱导类似催眠状态的一种植物。它
actually lethal in high doses. So naturally when the name Bella started to appear in the writings around town, Professor Murray thought that this could be linked to Bella Donna. Not only that, there was a pub nearby named Egypt's tent and it had long been rumoured as being haunted. And of course conveniently there was also rumours of witches' covens operating in the Hadley Woods areas over the years but it was nothing more than rumour and innuendo. Professor Murray's theories are a bit of a stretch and there's a serious lack of any hard evidence. In 1945 there was another murder that got her attention and she urged police to treat both cases as related. She was convinced satanic forces were at work. On the 14th of February
在高剂量下实际上是致命的。因此，当“贝拉”这个名字开始出现在小镇各处的字迹中时，默里教授自然认为这可能与颠茄有关。不仅如此，附近还有一家名为“埃及帐篷”（Egypt's Tent）的酒吧，长期以来一直有闹鬼的传闻。当然，顺理成章地，多年来也有关于黑格利森林地区有女巫结社活动的传闻，但这不过是谣言和暗讽罢了。默里教授的理论有点牵强，而且严重缺乏确凿证据。1945年发生了另一起引起她注意的谋杀案，她敦促警方将这两起案件联系起来处理。她坚信有撒旦力量在作祟。在1945年
1945 74-year-old Charles Walton of the Lullaby-Quinton area was found dead. He had been beaten, had his throat slashed with a hook and then pinned to the ground with a pitchfork. Some reports suggest he had a cross carved into his chest but this is inconclusive. There were rumours flowing around that Charles was somehow killed by a witch's ritual but these are largely unsubstantiated. It's much more likely Charles was killed by a known person in the area Alfred Potter and it had nothing to do at all with the Bella case. And if you're one who likes to sit around and ponder different theories and try and work out exactly what happened while you're in luck because there's yet another theory.
2月14日，来自拉拉比-奎顿（Lullaby-Quinton）地区的74岁老人查尔斯·沃尔顿（Charles Walton）被发现死亡。他遭到殴打，喉咙被钩子割破，然后被干草叉钉在地上。一些报告显示他的胸膛上被刻了一个十字架，但这尚无定论。有传言称查尔斯是以某种女巫仪式被杀的，但这些大都未经证实。查尔斯更有可能是被当地的熟人阿尔弗雷德·波特（Alfred Potter）杀害的，这与贝拉案完全没有关系。如果你是那种喜欢坐下来琢磨各种不同理论、试图弄清楚究竟发生了什么的人，那你有福了，因为还有一个理论。
A report made by a police officer in 1944 states that he was speaking to a local prostitute in Birmingham. The prostitute mentioned that there was a co-worker by the name of Bella who used to take clients to the Hadley Woods area and she hadn't been seen for about three years. It seemed to be more believable than the witchcraft theory but again there were problems. Why come forward with this information now? Why wasn't Bella reported missing? If this is a true story wouldn't you have mentioned something when the writing started up here on the walls around town? It seemed to be a pretty convenient story and it was never confirmed if there ever was a prostitute by the name of Bella working in the area.
1944年的一份警察报告指出，他当时正在伯明翰与一名当地妓女交谈。这名妓女提到，有一个名叫贝拉的同事过去常常带客户去黑格利森林地区，而且她已经有大约三年没露面了。这似乎比巫术理论更可信，但同样存在问题。为什么现在才提供这些信息？为什么贝拉没有被报失踪？如果这是一个真实的故事，当小镇各处墙壁上开始出现这些字迹时，你难道不应该提一下吗？这似乎是一个非常便利的故事，而且从未得到证实该地区是否真的有一个名叫贝拉的妓女在工作。
And there would be all sorts of reasons and benefits and favours to be gained as to why someone would want to feed false information to police. In 2014 a group of engineers got together and tried to make sense of all these different theories and information surrounding the case. Norman Fenton and Martin Neal of the Risk and Information Management Research Group from the School of Electronic Engineering and Computer Science at the Queen Mary University of London studied the case and came up with a statistical analysis of all the name facts and information. It's an interesting study but even they will be the first to admit that the results could be pretty rough and they would vary widely depending on what assumptions you rely on when
而且，出于各种原因、利益和好处，有人可能会想向警方提供虚假信息。2014年，一群工程师聚集在一起，试图理清围绕该案的所有这些不同理论和信息。伦敦玛丽女王大学电子工程与计算机科学学院风险与信息管理研究集团的诺曼·芬顿（Norman Fenton）和马丁·尼尔（Martin Neal）研究了该案，并对所有已知的名字、事实和信息进行了统计分析。这是一项有趣的研究，但他们自己也会首先承认，结果可能会相当粗略，并且会根据你在分析时所依据的假设而产生很大差异
in putting all the data into the case. So for example these results are highly dependent on the assumption that police really did exhaust all avenues of inquiry in relation to the missing person record searches. But I mean how do we really know that for sure? So if you change that assumption to police didn't exhaust all avenues of inquiry then the results change dramatically. So whilst interesting these results probably prove nothing it's just another thing to ponder. But what they came up with was the following. There was a 99% chance the cause of death was criminal. A 97% chance Bella was not British. A 93% chance Bella was still alive when put into the tree. A 33% chance that Jack Mossott was involved in her death. A 25% chance Bella was a spy. And a 16%
在把所有数据输入案例中时。比如，这些结果高度依赖于警方确实穷尽了失踪人口记录查询中所有调查途径的假设。但我的意思是，我们怎么能百分之百确定呢？因此，如果你把假设改成警方并没有穷尽所有调查途径，那么结果就会发生戏剧性的变化。所以，这些结果虽然有趣，但可能什么也证明不了，它只是又一个供人思考的问题。但他们得出的结论如下：死因是刑事案件的概率为99%。贝拉不是英国人的概率为97%。贝拉被放入树中时还活着的概率为93%。杰克·莫索特参与她死亡的概率为33%。贝拉是间谍的概率为25%。还有16%
chance that she was a prostitute. So I guess you can make her that what you will. So who was Bella and where did she come from? Who killed her and how did they kill her? Who wrote the messages around Tian? So many questions and so much mystery yet there's another twist to this story. Bella is missing. No one knows where she is. You see she wasn't buried instead her remains were taken by Professor Webster for further examination. Once he completed his examination he handed the bones over to a colleague in Birmingham University Medical School for further tests and research. And somehow over the years Bella disappeared from there without a trace. Not only that all the lab records and forensic files that
她是一名妓女的概率。所以我想你可以随心所欲地理解它。那么贝拉是谁？她来自哪里？谁杀了她？他们是怎么杀她的？是谁在蒂安周围写下了这些留言？有这么多的问题和谜团，但这故事还有另一个转折。贝拉失踪了。没有人知道她在哪里。你看，她并没有被安葬，相反，她的遗体被韦伯斯特教授拿去作进一步检查。完成检查后，他把骨骼交给了伯明翰大学医学院的一位同事，以进行进一步的测试和研究。不知怎的，多年来，贝拉就在那里消失得无影无踪。不仅如此，所有与她遗体在一起的实验室记录和法医档案也
were with her remains disappeared too. Just vanished. Dropped off the face of the earth. Unfortunately it isn't unusual for important pieces of evidence to get missing over the years in cold cases as we've already heard in previous episodes of this podcast. But this was significantly different. They somehow managed to lose an entire skeleton. Somebody's whole remains. Was Bella deliberately taken? Maybe further evidence of some sort of spy involvement or some sort of conspiracy? Or was she deliberately lost as part of an elaborate cover-up involving a well-connected killer? Or was she just accidentally lost or maybe thrown away? We will probably never know and of course this eliminates the hope of ever being able to use
也跟着消失了。就这样凭空消失了。从地球上蒸发了。不幸的是，正如我们在本播客先前的剧集里已经听到过的那样，在多年积案中，重要证据丢失并不罕见。但这有着重大区别。他们竟然弄丢了一整副骨架。整整一个人的遗骸。贝拉是被故意带走的吗？这可能是某种间谍卷入的进一步证据，还是某种阴谋？抑或是为了掩盖涉及背景深厚的凶手的精心策划而故意弄丢的？还是说她只是不小心丢失了，或者可能被扔掉了？我们可能永远也不会知道了，当然，这也消除了使用以下方法的希望
DNA testing in this case. In the meantime I guess all we can do is keep asking the question Who put Bella in a witch arm? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本案中的DNA检测。与此同时，我想我们能做的就是不断追问这个问题：是谁把贝拉放进了一棵巫婆榆树里？本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。